this is LL Cool J buzz okay you gonna be
lonely
[Music]
hey it's Alicia Watkins the bottom will
Merlin here 24 years old what's good
[Music]
little count for real because she be
giving it uh okay like for real I feel
like back then I mean now to know cuz
well she was like the beauty was with
all burgundy look at red hair you want
to tell me she wasn't doing it literally
my personal style is just facade shiho's
[Laughter]
but I see hope I got my top for my mom
no this is like when I'm saying like ID
but when a dime okay yes this is my
mother's shirt when she went to Aruba I
don't know how much the cosplay it's
from Aruba so it's real cute I feel like
oh my god just want him to do the bare
minimum I don't want him to do a lot
like I like a guy that's just like if
it's just like a regular day like okay
you know maybe like a matching sweat
suit like I'm not mad at a gray sweat
suit a navy blue sweater what a nice
watch
I am not too confident about picking a
man based on his outfit because snakes
can be fine too like that's just it like
I feel like it's more chewy alright so
I'm ready to look at these outfits let's
go find me you mean my name is Gerald
Houston in 30 years old and I'm from
Kansas City Missouri I'm more of a
street dressers I like speed where I
like designer clothes I'm a sneaker here
I love sneakers I love Easy's Jordans I
like Gucci shoes you know products I
know my outfits will get picked over the
other guys because I looked at the other
guy's outfits and for one they all got a
jury that Juliet even real yo King
cannot be walking around with a dude
with that jury oh if you know the jury
fact that many fake
I got drift you know don't you want to
look good looks when I have somebody
taking all your mom and your dad and
your bonuses and show them to all your
friends yeah you need a guy like me with
drink that's what my office a drip all
over we want to sit to the other
competitors is guarding to get some real
jewelry
hey I'm Taj I'm 26 I'm from Los Angeles
my style is very comfortable chic and
true to my roots why I think my land is
very diverse like you know it's kind of
comfortable but it shows some upscale
they show some class a little bit not
nothing too wild nothing too crazy just
classic my style says I'm confident but
not cocky because I feel that's a little
bit too much I don't like to draw too
much attention but I still want to come
and see Mitch when I walk into it
my name is Trey Taylor I'm 27 years old
and I'm from South Carolina I think my
fashion is a direct reflection of my
personality it is random as hell one day
you gonna get either way just when I'm
stepping outside with a look it stands
out it stands out it's simple it's kind
of subtle but if you saw it you'll be
interested in like you'll pay attention
to it without being like oh regular next
I think my outfit specifically says I'm
fun but I also got my [ __ ] together and
I also believe my outfit says I have
style and who has time to walk around
with somebody looking like whatever so
the other two guys that are competing
for this day I mean if it's for you it's
for you alright y'all so let's go into
these outfits outfit number one
he's a drug dealer
you got a pass I mean y'all doing is
that no it's nice or do you know I hate
everything about it she said she like
that's a strong word ma'am I don't even
know how to explain this and I like
coats like this but the fact that it's
all metallic like this like I don't even
know if I'm really baby I wore it I
would be like all right cool but the way
is paired up with this outfit right now
I like the shoes no back I'm just not
feeling this outfit all this metallic
wood this cuz it's silver metallic with
this gold he got a tennis necklace the
Michael Kors that's just not making any
I don't even know where this even came
from so I'm just off it and then the
acid-wash jeans by she odd right you
can't hold nothing no there's no
punching so we're gonna move on to the
second fit a little surprise boy at the
end I liked it oh wow
colors this man is into it this man
loves his patterns this is looking crazy
as well these men are dressing crazy
okay I like that jacket come looking
dusty to you I the shoes these shoes
this cute like I like the the baby blue
dupatta blue whatever let's put that bag
he could have fixed this up I feel like
if you would've took this away and took
this away if it was like a white
button-up I feel like it would be a
little bit more classic this shirt my
favorite part of me that's I love this
shirt if he kind of just closed
everything we would be in money for sure
hmm okay the backhander come this was
you you almost was dead Oh like if you
would have just what is y'all doing like
what is up with y'all like y'all just
wanted to burst of flavor something like
I'm not really sure what y'all got going
on where are y'all from where are y'all
from cuz I feel like it's a little
country of here I still didn't feel
content confident like for good reason
because she came in every company yo
it's not that I feel confident my my
fear I didn't feel confident like her
answers can you see she was already
coming off while I'm rethinking my back
may like she'll have nothing nice to say
you know if I see you in this outfit and
you kill it I'll give you your price but
and to further notice
this ain't it I don't have it like I
still haven't lost any confidence in my
house it does just that's our choice we
just want to move on out to outfit
number three all right it's my turn I'm
ready to see what she got you got a big
done it's chilly out
[Music]
okay so I can already tell you when just
looking at this I'm getting very bad
bunny vibes I don't know if it's the
snakeskin jackets
it's a lot um the neon green I feel like
it's a lot but I'm low-key this is
probably one of the best ones cuz I feel
like I don't know what vibe is giving me
but it's cleaner than the other ones
it's more it's more consistent oh you
wanna brother we are going the
Balenciaga yeah I'm expecting your shoes
[Laughter]
like pretty clean you know you might got
some you know you got some money
you got some clothes you don't got way
to [ __ ] everyday like these people oh I
can't wait to talk to sis what's this I
don't know I don't know if you have
curly hair what a girl you was wit have
curly hair but it's on there I don't
know who you was messing with I have
curly yeah
the only natural but we don't relax
period what is let me just do you a
favor
I'm gonna take it all maybe we can get
this back after the GT after right
that's a future bro you got to hear
actually talking guys the guys just make
sure she stop touching issues like that
y'all good I see babies you know future
let's let this die you might as well let
this die to you because what is this I
don't know I'm like nothing about this I
think your Suri's is all off this is
outfit now this is an outfit oh my god
go with outfit when I pulled up I know
it's bad to say I feel like I will wear
this look are we matching so hey
everything bad is already in his pockets
so um if we just keep that pocket
clothes we don't got no problems
that brings it together with the Rings
and it just is all consistency scale of
one to ten what would I read this fit a
one those shoes literally gave you that
one but everything else I grabbed the
whole this is crazy looking I feel
disrespected me I feel like she ain't
got no sense of style my Jackie
well my time I'm gonna give him a five
cuz like even though the jacket save it
like it's too like this it's a little
dusty like this jacket is old like and
it's nothing wrong but Oh stuff is just
take care of it like so I would give
this outfit a clean seven because I just
feel like the colors that go with it I
like this jacket for myself so you know
maybe we could swap my damn um but if I
had to pick I would definitely eat the
spit hey hey gratulations my brother
yeah I'm saying I mean look
congratulations my brother we're gonna
see him in these outfits and we don't
see
let's go um super nervous cuz I dragged
majority of home squats me target my
yeah
Gaza Taj I'm 26 from LA so you're right
we said neighborhood that's that's two
here grew at least here like she said
she spoke from her art she said exactly
how she felt I'm not what can I do
Kanaka for it yes that's her
my name is Jerome came to see yo she
said she didn't like my she hated my
face just like my face they seemed like
my team man Jackie seeing like my ass he
was name but she did like my shoes
though I'm cool with that
I love my shoes my name is Trey I'm 27
years old
it looks like a lot when it's like on
the rack but when it's on it definitely
looks a lot more subtle a lot more
chilling I actually just I go together
now that I see the guys in the office I
think
going to choose now that she chose me
yeah we just left the shoot Lisa had a
change of heart and pick me even though
she hates my outfit so we got to talk
about our sense of style our sit our
sense of style
[Music]
Lycia claiming my [ __ ] was like it took
me back yo I like high school days like
she got one of those tight days not you
know anything was wrong with that guy
but you know offices a little bit you
know intrigue they they was a real good
vibe like you know like I got to see
like some of the things already kind of
felt like you know I knew deep down like
she's she's really a dope girl she's a
beautiful clean you know
raw so I appreciate it at all so yeah I
can see myself going out again with
least arrows already in the works
and I appreciate the experience as well
so thank you I'm excited about it let's
just see where those
[Music]
[Music]